good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday hope everyone
is having a fabulous teachy
I am I'm thrilled that it's Friday I'm
thrilled that th EO is here on TGIF it's
only appropriate he's in position for
the show the other day he was out of
frame and so everyone just gets the
blessing that is th EO do to Theodora do
to do to the adora o do to do to
Theodora crunchy angel Dora perfect
chairman Dora Oh wonderful
angel Dora I love him Dora light of my
life Dora perfect fetch Dora apple of my
eye Dora I love my iTunes were peanut
butter to my jelly Dora Dora we're still
glad to have a special guest here today
and that is Theo he is gonna help us
deliver a fabulous show for you guys
because there's so much going on there's
still no TV recap but that's not gonna
stop us from just being fabulous for
like 45 minutes it will not stop us our
episodes have been so short and it's
like no it's not our fault it's just
because there's like nothing going on in
the world but I find myself being like
very very Hardy very very very wordy
just so like I add time to the show it's
like I'm writing a paper I feel the need
to be short and narrowly verbose yes
there's no television recap xual at the
end of each episode of the morning toast
I'd like the news lately hasn't been
like super salacious you know it's just
been like kind of sad yeah I agree
so we're doing our best to stretch these
[ __ ] out as much as we can just know
that we are aware of the problem and
we're working on it um also speaking of
just lengthy episodes we posted another
patreon episode yesterday part 2 of
general QA and part 2 of being honest
raw real urban organic that's what
happens behind the paywall you know like
[ __ ] we're getting naked right so if you
just like want to hear from us hear what
we're up to how we're feeling head to
patreon.com/scishow morning toast that
is our fourth episode of the month if
you're not aware patreon is our
subscription service for $7.99 a month
to get 5 extra episodes
they're always a little bit more
behind-the-scenes things we don't share
on the toast but their podcast their
vlogs they seem to be really well like
so and there am i highly recommend to
the patrons just let me know your
thoughts on that chili cook-off I'm
still waiting for the masses to let me
know we're marinating on this idea for
our final episode of the month and
Jackie has a great idea to vlog the
great chili cook-off between me and then
I will be the judge obviously and I
think I'll do it because I want to cook
a chili like everyone loves the blogs so
much and I I wanted to taste what Ben
might be cooking up in the kitchen Ben
like I don't want to blow my husband's
spot up and I'm so grateful that he
doesn't watch the show because I'm about
to say something that would really hurt
his feelings I know what its gonna be
anything it needs to be said you get Ben
um probably cooks the most in our family
his dad is a chef and he's just always
had this kind of desire to be like
culinary and because we don't cook that
much in my house I never really thought
much of it but in quarantine we've been
cooking so much and I kind of want to
say like Ben is a terrible cook damn
like let it rip sis and I don't know if
it's just like he cooks things I would
never eat like eggs and salami yes but
it just never looks very good and when
he does make things that I like like not
to be like such a [ __ ] but it's like
not good okay so like what are some of
the things I feel like you guys are
always making tacos and the meat is just
never right okay well when we make tacos
I make it and I made it last night it
was just when no but like you guys are
always having like a meat problem well
we are going through an issue where it's
like with quarantine we've been loading
up on kosher meat and like every time I
take grill chicken out of the freezer
and defrost it like it's disgusting like
it's like raw I just I don't understand
like the whole defrosting what is your
difference I didn't understand the whole
defrosting thing I was like I'll just
put it in the stove like it'll know and
I learned today when I tried to cook a
frosted thank God it was a beyond meat
burger because it didn't matter that I
ate it wrong right not real meat but
then I understood the power of
defrosting and a lot of times with
cooking what I've learned is like you
need to learn the lessons the hard way
it's not enough for someone to tell you
like meat must be defrosted for three
days you need to experience new yeah you
put in the fridge for three days
maybe that's why you got a defrosting
problem no I take it out in the morning
and I leave it in the sink to defrost
yeah okay you're weird
oh I put a new kitchen I do
frig you can't leave raw meat unfrozen
in the fridge for three days like having
a 48 hour I do like two days in the
fridge and it works for me
okay well all I'm trying to say is my
husband's like not that great of a cook
and I'm that's what quarantine has
opened my eyes to but I think he's just
like riding his dad's coattails you know
because he's got some fabulous chef and
Ben's just not but I appreciate he has
so much passion for the for the craft
that it almost helps the food taste
better th EO has perked up a little bit
cuz like he hears you talking [ __ ] about
his dad but I also think that th EO has
gotten that culinary bug a little bit
know and I think he's going to be a
master chef you know what being a dog is
so great cuz like you literally get the
same dry piece of [ __ ] twice a day like
you're so excited about it yeah well we
don't know like how he actually feels no
no no he like leaps from the bed can't
wait like licking my leg until I put the
food down like it is the best part of
his day and he's actually eating like
garbage he's such a leg liquor and I
think it's because he loves the taste of
tan looks like when I tan looks on my
legs I had tan looks on my legs today
and he I can't keep him away from him
well you just simply it resists bugs
having royal canin with a side of ten
lakhs
we're looking on with this Royal Canin
Jackie Canaan Canaan then you're making
it like the biblical place Kanaan no
Royal Canin so we've a fabulous show we
do um anything else you want to tell the
class before we just like take a dive
off the deep end
no I feel as though this has been a
great week I'm just - like recap it I'm
so excited to be back in studio so
excited people are watching on YouTube
again and I'm just looking forward to
the continued journey I am so happy to
be back on in the studio I literally
like I didn't realize how much I needed
that routine in my life right until it
was taken away from me um and I'm just
so excited like to keep decorating our
space literally I'm having such a
[ __ ] problem I'm shouting out DHL and
they're just terrible customer service
like I have this fabulous mural coming
for the back and they just like decided
they didn't want to deliver it and then
they sent it back I'm like are you
kidding it's just like so much drama
with the postal system so DHL you're on
my list but I'm just really excited for
it to come together and I'm so happy
everyone's watching and just you know
we're pretty bare-bones but look up
there
we'll get there yeah we always do so I
think without further ado it is time for
the past five stories that Theo needs to
know before he wakes up and take a bite
out of his morning bone and that's true
but as you remember we are going to be
highlighting once a week a black owned
business that we love or that we've
discovered or that someone has suggested
to us and I'm really excited about this
one because I had a fabulous choice to
reach out who works with a bunch of
black owned businesses and she suggested
a ton of them and today's episode is
naked perfection spa founded by Courtney
Gayle and located in Brooklyn
naked perfection spa provides treatments
to clients of all skin types striving to
build confidence in everyone by
enhancing the beauty of their individual
appearance one person at a time Courtney
is a New York State licensed esthetician
and aesthetics instructor but she didn't
start out in this illustrious industry
read at a school she was a young
Brooklyn Brooklyn girl who grew up with
her mom and siblings and moved around
quite a bit
she worked in retail many many years on
Fifth Avenue and decided that she wasn't
making a big enough impact on people
she liked makeup but it was too
superficial to fall in love with
Courtney wanted to tap into a skill set
that could change someone's confidence
for the long term and positively so
Courtney maxed out on what she could do
as far as credentials and studies and
started naked perfection spa she didn't
have the world behind her and she didn't
start with loans and funding because she
started but she started because she had
a set of skills that she said it could
help people courtney became an
aesthetics instructor a few years after
she opened her own studio in new york
she decided to teach because to know the
knowledge she had to give young men and
women as far was far beyond what the
authors of a textbook could write
Courtney's experiences weren't science
but her willpower and resiliency was not
something you could buy nor train and
her faith is what brought her this far
no matter how many time people have
tried to tear her down and said she
could never do this or that she started
and is still going gears farther than it
than they'd ever imagined
Courtney built confidence from the
inside out with her education and her
hands her students and her clients from
all demographics and walks of life one
person at a time
naked perfection spa is located in
Brooklyn and will be reopening for all
services between phases 3 & 4 fabulous
this includes facials body treatments
peels even eyelash extension to learn
more about naked perfection spa and
receive $10 off the entire site visit
naked perfection spa calm and use the
code
toasty 10 sets Toa sty 10 to Teo a sty
1:02 shop products or book
post quarantine spa treatment again
that's naked perfection spot.com check
it out Wow I will be booking my posse
Florentine spa treatment I've never been
so excited for anything facial oh my god
that sound like fabulous can a Buell us
that is a simple request holding
fabulous bigger and better best okay
look how we both knew like that was the
line to stop so you're at yeah well
sometimes I do a really good job at
cheating it where it's like I could
continue if it was a continuation or I
could be stopped you read the room
I read the room it's no okay are you
ready for our first story it's such
exciting news we are on our ship we have
in for a while as our there is a new bed
that on the ship because emma roberts is
pregnant expecting her first child with
boyfriend garrett hedlund
i mean of all the girls in all the world
to end up with like the man of my dreams
from some of literally my favorite
movies in case you're not familiar
Garrett had lung pate played in Country
Strong he was the lead male role I'm
sorry I forgot his name and then he also
was in Georgia rule but he was like that
iconic college shooting who was he lying
to give a [ __ ] to on the rowboat in
the middle of the lake it was just so
iconic and I absolutely loved Garrett
Hedlund and I love these two together I
love these two together and also I I
feel strongly about card had one but I
also feel like of all the women in the
world
I'm sorry of all the men in the world to
secure Emma Roberts like literally in my
opinion one of the most eligible
bachelorettes in the world like I truly
adore her so I'm so happy for her for
them and it's I'm also happy for me
because I feel like at one point there
was like a breakup rumor between the two
of them and now like this confirms to me
that they are together they are having a
future together and they're not thirsty
or anything there's actually so private
it's been confusing over the last few
years to know what their actual status
was and this is just a fabulous life
update you know babies being brought
into the world by - absolutely stunning
people you just love to see it you do
you do and this really is a quarantine
bebut I mean I don't know exactly how
far along she is Us Weekly does not have
that level of detail and this was a
major scoop for us weekly they were the
first people that got it he's being like
super Scooby these days what was the
other thing they had I forget yeah but
we were talking about it yeah whatever I
don't know I feel like there was two
things that they had Rhys
and good for them love to see it
congratulations House weekly on this
scoopy Scoob you're really giving TMZ
any news like a run for your money
that you are I'm proud I'm proud I know
there are a lot of toasters actually
work at Us Weekly so I see you and we're
proud I really like us like I know we
said on the show like we have a lot of
respect for People magazine before yes
which we do completely but like US
Weekly is right up there for me I agree
under like all the tabloid trash it goes
People magazine at the top and then
right there Us Weekly and with scoops
like this they're really making their
way unto a real contender for People
magazine yeah they really are
in terms of airport magazines right
thank you for the scoop congratulations
to the happy couple and I look forward
to continuing on this journey I actually
look forward to like seeing Emma Roberts
be the most beautiful pregnant woman
like she's just so stunning and stylish
already right and she gets invited to
the most fabulous events she was just
like started her career as Hollywood
royalty and she was just like invited
fabulous places though she was
unfabulous true from the start so like
this baby's gonna be even more fabulous
this is gonna be Julia Roberts great
nice yeah at that point like there's no
real word for like the connection
between Julia Roberts in the bebut like
in terms of lineage like a really not
great needs I don't know that's not a
thing I think it is and it's not really
thing so anyways I think congratulations
to the whole family congratulations I'm
so happy I just I love them it's like do
you know who your great aunt is actually
yeah yeah I guess yeah you know what I'm
saying
yeah great aunt is the thing but great
niece is not thank you I feel that oh
thank you okay next story is also some
exciting casting news that's really just
taking the world by storm Elizabeth
Banks has been cast as Miss Frizzle in
the Magic School Bus live-action film
that is the most perfect casting if I've
ever seen it a hundred were sent to the
bus the first lie back the first
live-action Magic School Bus feature
film is on its way with Elizabeth Banks
set to star as the quirky and
adventurous science teacher miss Valerie
Frizzle according to The Hollywood
Reporter the word quirky was invented to
describe miss Frizzle and then Emma
Stone
yeah she
so quirky quite quirky that also would
have been a good casting actually but
Elizabeth this is your favorite perky
also not to be like a chest or anything
but miss fizzle is like more of an adult
yeah and I think of Elizabeth Banks says
I don't even know if it's true I just
think of her as an older woman than Emma
Stone yeah miss Frizzle is actually the
ultimate counselor yeah and so I know
that counselor snitch will be right
there in mind to get a ticket honestly
she is the ultimate counselor but like I
would be calling like the the AAC the
American Association of camps because
she was very irresponsible like taking
those kids on a flying the ACA they see
a American Camp Association yeah I know
but like she always got them home safely
and she knew what she was doing but then
wearing seatbelts or anything I don't
know it was kind of a hazard I know I
feel like the live-action adaptation
will kind of write those wrong yeah and
make sure that everyone is safely seat
belted and feeling safe and like the
parents know the kids are gonna be fine
this is just such an interesting choice
to do as live-action because it's
technically super irrelevant like in in
modern times but like for us kids it was
a formative experience watching that
show and I think a movie or show book
Magic School Bus
book it is a book but they made into a
TV show oh yeah I guess she's drawn here
uh maybe is a children's book series it
was a TV show the film adaptation is
based on the popular scholastic
children's book series of the same name
and follows eccentric teacher miss
Frizzle and her class on their field
trips in a magic yellow school bus okay
but they also turned it into a feature
film marks the first big-screen
adaptation in the franchise's 26 years
was putting it on is it a Pixar it's
Elizabeth Banks his production company
brownstone oh she does good work folks
she does with cartoons I do prefer to
leave it to it's just a cartoon no it's
live action oh I'm sorry I apologize I
totally misunderstood the story live
action oh so the bus is really gonna fly
yeah it's gonna be really fabulous
Elizabeth Banks is the person to kind of
anchor this this whole project yeah and
I feel like she definitely has a lot of
respect for the Magic School Bus
franchise to begin with you know she
probably grew up with it yeah so I think
she'll really do it justice and she has
a lot of Miss fizzell in her she does
she uses fizzle yeah she uses Frizzle
first sorry I also think like memes
about Miss Frizzle like never don't
make me laugh ya know she's an iconic
character and I look forward to as banks
breathing new life into her and like
really use all the means of miss Frizzle
like one she's a real human being are
gonna be fabulous yeah and I hope that
she depicts her as we remember her you
know like a strong a strong female ya
know an independent woman she might have
been like the first real strong female
that like we encountered it but a role
model yeah she like took that school
like that class of kids all on her own
yeah she was really kind of iconic yes
she she is quite iconic and I'm so
excited about this through and then
today's generation of children will
watch this movie and this is something
that we all they'll have their own
associations and we have ours and it's
all something we can come together on
that's not that and that's the power of
Miss Frizzle in the Magic School Bus
that's the power that's you said it says
okay next story the Dixie Chicks have
changed their name what wrapping the
Dixie you haven't heard this you know
the chicks the chicks they're the show
the chicks
goodbye Dixie amid calls for the removal
of Confederate symbols and nostalgia
prompted by the black lives matter
movement the notoriously liberal country
music trio formerly known as the Dixie
Chicks have finally decided that Dixie
had to die now simply the chicks the
band mates who have sold some 333
million worldwide have changed their
name forgive me for being ignorant what
is so it's an association with the
mason-dixon line okay Dixon Dixie and
their the Dixie Chicks and they dropped
it oh that's interesting okay
the chicks is kind of like a better name
I like it I'm surprised that there's not
like a girl band already with that name
totally but I just like in recent years
I become like a Dixie Chicks stand till
the day I die mostly because Taylor
should have told me to but I just heard
that song I'm not ready to make nice and
like if you're ever in my proximity when
that song comes on I just strongly urge
you to walk away like it's it's a
powerful thing and not everyone can hit
that song I'm not ready to make
nice I'm actually that's not really the
pitiful part allow me the powerful part
is I made my bed and I sleep like I'm a
man with no with no regrets and I don't
mind saying it's a sad sad story my
mother will teach your daughter that you
gotta hit up her big finger and how in
the world getting the ones that I said
sending somebody so over the and [ __ ]
they don't write me a letter saying that
I better shut up and sing or my life
will be over
I just wanted like if that songs ever on
like just walk away oh it's for the best
you know what song I've been diggin
these days what gasps laughter Deena
doin anything to get your abandoned I
mean my limited experience with the
child's with the dixie chicks was
landslide which was just like I don't
think it was their song I believe Stevie
Nicks wrote it but they made it for me
at like you know so did Glee but that
was a powerful scene when Santana and
Brittany are both confessing their love
for one another but I digress um ya know
they've just kind of like been a little
bit ahead of my time the Dixie Chicks
and I feel like I'm getting caught up
now yeah you are and now they're the
chicks the chicks I think that's so cute
it's gonna be hard though it is they've
been around for a while like it's gonna
be hard to disassociate a rebrand is OE
it's hard what would no matter what
you're doing you know remember the
morning breath right so it'll take
everyone a little time to address but I
think we'll get there yeah yeah yeah and
then you can't remember the time when it
was the other thing yeah but it's like
nobody really called the Dixie Chicks
anything other than the Dixie Chicks
whereas like with Lady a people called
them lady a for a while like the name
transition wasn't that crazy yeah but
there were also people who are calling
them Lady Anne ths and so I think those
two dueling schools have thought those
people are the real fans
there's the they're the only opinion
who's matter who matters I agree even
though I'm gonna be really controversial
right now and say something kind of
crazy um you would think that like
Taylor Swift doing a collab with the
Dixie Chicks like with my newfound
appreciation for them would be like the
best thing ever but I they're not really
on it and I actually wish they weren't
on it because it's such like a personal
song mm-hmm so yeah I said it yeah I was
saying I'm like a proper duet where you
could hear all of the people I didn't
even hear any and something that you
really want to like rock out too yeah
not like cry in your car
yeah not something that you can't like
listen next to another what's so funny
is with with Tik Tok you know it's like
the videos that you engage with most end
up dictating what comes up on your for
you page so the algorithm is very much
like giving you what they think you
and I guess it engaged with like a lot
of tick-tock Taylor Swift content and
I've now I'm now on the Taylor Swift
side of tick-tock and the changes for
while I was on the ariana grande I
decided to tack which like I wasn't mad
about but I just didn't understand how I
got there but I very much understood how
I ended up in the Taylor Swift I decided
tick tock and I just say it's a fabulous
place to be that does sound fabulous
congratulations Thanks thank you ready
for our next race it's more happy couple
news
thank God like yesterday your stories
were like it really make me want to cry
I'm sorry I can't
like predict do you know I know I'm not
blaming it um but Billie lourd is
engaged to Austin Riedel who so he's her
like a man that she dated when she was
younger
they rekindled after like her split from
Taylor Lautner and I'm gonna try Vanilli
the Lord Taylor Lautner did yes and now
she's engaged it's just like a big news
day for scream queen alums oh and I
guess he's also from book-smart oh let
me see this picture because I just
assumed he was like on Thursday the
book-smart actresses oh no cheese in
books oh yeah I was like wow I feel so
yeah
the book-smart actress is now fiance
Austin right now showed the happy news
on Instagram writing that saying as to
his proposal was a no-brainer for bored
he captioned his Instagram she said yes
actually she said duh but I guess that's
even better than yes um on Valentine's
Day he got over her calling her the best
girl in the world he said I found the
best girl in the world happy Valentine's
Day to us you know what like sometimes
you hear about couples getting together
or getting engaged you just like know
that like this is the end of the road
for them like this is gonna be it and I
just feel that way I feel like they both
find out well I don't know him but I
feel like she has found well I don't
know her either but I think I do she is
found like the forever and I feel like
she needed that like after a really
tough few years I'm really happy for her
I'm really really happy for her this is
just some happy sweet news yeah and it's
just like a big day for people who have
been on scream queens at some point in
their lives
first i'ma Roberts oh my god yes and you
know that there's like not even rumors
because there's been confirmations but I
guess nothing's been filmed since Kobe
but like scream queens 3 yeah is
happening I heard it's happening you
guys I heard I would love to um actually
you know there was some tea there
because when Lea Michele got quite
unquote cancelled I hate use that word
like what
you say yeah a few weeks ago Avenue
there's other things you could say when
there was backlash there was controversy
controversy
I'm with Lea Michele we were we weren't
doing shows but there was like all this
stuff I'm sure everyone knows about it
and Abigail Breslin was like kind of
involved like saying that she had also
really negative experiences with Lea
Michele so if they do bring back scream
queens I'd be curious to see that the
on-screen dynamics and like the behind
the scenes dynamics I would love to like
be a fly on those walls
yes but forgive me if I'm wrong in terms
of the storyline but Lea Michele was
Hester and so it she's like a mass
murderer I think um so I don't know if
it necessarily makes sense to bring her
back unless they wanted to I'm sure they
can make it work I don't think that she
died in the show you mean storyline
wouldn't make sense like for her to
really be on yes she was like in a
maximum-security prison got it um I may
be the flash forward a few years yes I
think they broke her out maybe to help
get like the green meanie
I forgot it got really complex yes again
sometimes shows like especially towards
the end this is what we were talking
about with One Tree Hill they just like
lose all sense of reality like scream
queens started that way yeah that's true
so I'm just really excited I should
rewatch also speaking of Ryan Murphy's
incredible work politician season 2 is
streaming now and we're gonna watch this
weekend and when cap on Monday yeah I
mean we also have to watch our toast
movie of the week for Monday which is
black clansmen but I think I can make
time for both this weekend I'm not
really doing anything else
I actually I'm like in the middle of a
book and then I have to read the book
for the redhead so I actually have like
a full plate this week and I'm looking
forward to tons of content and it's been
a while since I'd literally turn my TV
on I get home and I literally scroll
tick tock it's it's honestly a really
sad existence like it's just pathetic
and like Ben comes in I like pretend
that I'm doing stuff so he's not gonna
like judge me when I've literally not
done anything except girl talk talk for
the last two hours and it's not like I'm
being creative and like making my own
take talks and like contributing to my
social footprint you know like which is
my job you know I'm literally just
sitting there scrolling yes so
entertaining and hours go by well
whatever you need whatever it takes for
you to be entertained in this time like
just embrace it you know I walked past
my bag of knitting supplies and it just
took me back to a time in quarantine
where like I was doing puzzles and
knitting like that was like so pure
yeah I need to get back to that place I
know that's where I not right now cuz
the past few weeks I've just been like
watching TV mostly just watching Real
Housewives of Potomac but I haven't been
really reading and I stopped using my
peloton and so yesterday I'm like back
on back doing like reading during the
day and on my peloton like that's where
I was two months ago but I don't know I
think I might have been better then I
don't know it's hard to associate when I
was good and when I was not during
quarantine quarantine is very cyclical
so you do something you get bored of it
then you completely change your routine
you get bored about you miss the old
thing that you were doing yes that's how
I was gonna say cyclical quite cyclical
I ready for the final story it is some
good news
that was it a little good news is it
some good news because if John
Krasinski's not gonna tell me I'm not
really a little okay it's a little a lgn
a little good news
yes exactly Tyler Perry is donated a van
to Atlanta based women's organization
that helps people experiencing
homelessness every time we say that we
report on Tyler Perry it's like why
aren't I married to him mm-hmm a women's
organization in Atlanta provides hot
that provides hygiene products to people
experiencing homelessness received a
very special gift on Thursday thanks to
Tyler Perry Eric Wright the founder of a
non-profit non-profit project you first
shared that the producer and actor
donated a brand new cargo van to the
organization which provides people who
need the basics for health hygiene and
love that is so cute
I mean in my in my eyes like Tyler Perry
when his time was up on this earth like
he is walking straight into heaven like
there's no [ __ ] questions nobody's
gonna ask to see his ID like he's just
[ __ ] walking in and I felt that way
ever that Trader Joe's story which is
like I totally broke my heart with the
actor who used to be on Cosby Cosby Show
yes this is just like this is not
surprising at all no not at all and it's
actually it's very philanthropic it's
very creative way to help out an
organization and I think it's beautiful
and I just wanted to share that I wanted
to end the past five stories on some
good positive philanthropic news yes and
you know what that reminds me of because
I finally if you didn't watch our
episodes last week which we were on
zoom' so I don't entirely blame you I
revealed that I actually finally
finished in Jessica Simpson's book after
much coursing from Jackie I just wasn't
in a headspace to read a book but when I
finally got into the headspace I
finished it in like two days
it was so good and that story about how
she like won some free car like
convertible and she asked a company if
she could trade it in for a minivan and
she ended up giving it to that like
orphanage that she was constantly
visiting in Dallas or Texas where she
was from like that was such a cute story
such a cute story I totally agree I
forgot about that tidbit but like when
she asked if he can trade the
convertible infirmity and the people
were like are you serious she like won a
free car from Chrysler and she's I can
actually get it like a Chrysler minivan
that Dan and they were like I think they
thought she was joking and she's like no
I'm dead serious and she like Jareau of
it through the gates of the orphanage
and like the kids are running around I
just [ __ ] ever since that book I now
follow her on Instagram which I can't
believe I didn't do before but like as
someone who has always felt so connected
to Jessica Simpson immediately because
we share the same birthday like the fact
that I didn't bother where like I'm a
disgraceful fan and I'm really ashamed
of myself and I apologize I do but now
that I am I'm like really trying to get
noticed by her I'm like being so thirsty
in her comments like love it icon I just
feel like following her on Instagram
wouldn't have the same impact before you
read the book a grade I I have such
respect for her like and her I
understand her personality I understand
her captions like I am glad that I
waited otherwise I might have like
judged her based on her Instagram for
sure before reading her book and
understanding like everything that she
is um so those were our past five
stories but we would be remiss we would
be devastated we would even be
heartbroken if we didn't share the most
piece of mindless news today in today's
segment Kelly's mindless news like the
fourth of July this one of course comes
from People magazine because only the
most mindless pieces of [ __ ] comes from
People magazine when it comes to Kelly
Ripa here is the head headline Kelly
Ripa and Mark Consuelos have set up a
chore wheel for their family
amid coronavirus Kelly Ripa and Mark
Consuelos have come up with a clever way
to ensure that their kids stay busy and
contribute to the family amid the
ongoing kovat 19 pandemic while speaking
with a parenting expert on monday's
broadcast of live with Kelly and Ryan
Ripa 49 revealed that she and her
husband have set up a family chore wheel
for their children as they continue to
shelter in place as a family during the
global health crisis even though it's
unclear where in fact they are currently
currently we've established a chore
wheel where everybody has a chore for
the week
she told parenting expert dr. Eileen
Kennedy more explaining
the family has been using the tool so
that somebody's vacuuming quote and
somebody does the dishes and somebody
does the laundry somebody cleans the
toilet throughout the week so you get
wet or you only have to do it once per
week you have to do it every day like
it's your responsibility for this week I
just hate the play-doh if the toilet is
dirty
everyone knows who to call every day
right and you know what I I think what
kind of triggers me about this story is
they're actually like Kelly Ripa like
invented chore wheels but that's so not
the case like the camp counselor embed
to the chore wheel counselor snitch
invented the toilet and I actually have
a lot of love in my heart for tour
wheels because I do find them to be
effective
really effective I just wait there's
more the mom of three went on to say the
toilet duty has been a very unpopular
chore amongst her family though they
switch every week so that no one is
stuck scrubbing the porcelain throne I
mean the fact that I now know that Kelly
Ripa's children scrub their toilets
during coronavirus like is exactly why
the segment Kelly's mindless news was
created in the first place
yes just to highlight like and I have to
say it really is mostly from People
magazine yeah as other people pick it up
but they are always the first so here's
the thing it's like she shares this
mindlessness on her show I think we've
broken this down before yeah because
they do banter at the beginning of the
show did you what we do yeah and that
doesn't bother me at all like that is
who she is she's the banter Queen I
don't understand why and how it turns
into news story well I want to know if
it's like that live with Kelly and Ryan
PR team like just pushing out mindless
content is it Kelly's personal publicist
like wanting more news about Kelly
or is it People magazine just being like
weirdly obsessed with Kelly Ripa I can't
imagine that it's the third I'm sorry I
just can't yeah I'm feeling like it's
the first like that ABC PR team just
wanting to get more buzz for live with
Kelly and Ryan perhaps but it's just
we're on to them we're on to them and
because it's so uninteresting like
there's so much uninteresting news that
out there that never even catches my eye
but it's like the sheer volume of crap
we have to read about Kelly Ripa it's
just cause for concern and that's why
you know we started the important work
that we do here at Kelly's mindless news
yeah yeah we're calling it out left and
right call it a Zia and that's our show
anything else we want to talk about oh I
do I don't know if you guys know but on
Tuesday of next week my comedy special
comes out it's called disgrace Queen it
is available for pre-order right now so
if you want to just get your all your
ducks in order you can head to iTunes
and type in disgraced Queen into iTunes
or you could tap the link in my bio on
my Instagram girl with no job it'll take
you right to the iTunes page and I would
really appreciate you supporting the
comedy special is my first special it's
my debut special I'm really proud of it
and I'm just so looking forward to
everyone seeing it on June 30th of next
week that's Tuesday that's when it comes
out that is so exciting like when he
first mounts the date I felt so far off
that far off and it was
yeah and now it is here around the
corner we have to watch we have to do
that cuz Street soiree well like when
when I first found out about the special
I was like I'm gonna rent a movie
theater like invite all my friends and
family and now I'm like still you know
not able to do that and no one's even in
New York so no one's gonna be able to
watch with me but people just like you
over and do and we'll watch sounds like
a party to me sounds like a perfect
evening anything you want to promote
she'll come on
oh I mean nothing gonna patreon.com
Sasha morning toast we're apartment
pouring our heart and souls into these
episodes for you guys so if you're
looking for a little extra content I
don't even know what people's schedules
are like right now because everyone's in
such different places in terms of the
quarantine and going back to work and
not so there's content abound over there
oh and if you're looking for some
presets to brighten up your summer flow
head you need a flow calm the new pastel
pack is everything of the sort
my favorite preset is cotton candy but
yesterday I used the toast preset on the
photo that I posted and it just changed
the game so Jackie I'll flow calm that's
what we do here we change the game thank
you so much for listening to the morning
to us the Millennial morning show where
we go live Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we are also available
as a podcast anywhere podcasts can be
found so that's about if I iTunes
stitcher public radio I harbor you know
cashbox all the places whoever you
listen to podcasts find us the morning
toast and leave a five star view about
how beautiful stunning and smart we are
we hope everyone has a fabulous weekend
stay safe have fun don't drink and drive
yes bye-bye